mes amis qui m'ont dit le manque pas ton
cou luc robillard 64 ans est loin de
regretter la question de son vélo à
assistance électrique acheté il ya un an
si tu veux faire des grandes ron des
grandes rail à ce moment là les bonnes
tourner sa présence en prend le vélo
électrique c'est grâce à ce vélo qu'il a
pu compléter le tour de l'île de
montréal sans trop de misère il n'est
pas le seul à pouvoir s'en contenter
aujourd'hui alors que j'ai un peu
d'argent même nom mais moins fort c'est
comme la côte de berry l'eau c'est
facile à monter
les vélos électriques sont plus que
jamais au sommet de leur popularité ils
représentaient en 2020 selon vélo québec
le quart des vélos vendus dans la
province
ce réparateur de ville ou rencontrés en
marge du tour de l'île y observe
plusieurs bénéfices ça permet de le
rendre le sport accessible à plus de
gens qui sont pas nécessairement aussi
en forme que
la commune est mortelle on peut bien ce
qu'on paie pour un bon vélo électrique
de 2 à 4 milles alors je dirais que
c'est le règne complet on avait beaucoup
plus cher et en inde est moins
dispendieux mais on les voit beaucoup en
réparation les moins chères lui ici
c'est doussain à douce elle ça fait ça
donne une bonne right management des
coûts entrants détail ce coup là c'est
le cookie tropez deux jeux tous les
matchs importants à ce moment là ça va
tu sais le plus tard
oui c'est cher à l'achat mais au final
ça se rentabilise reconnaissance à payer
sept bonds ne t'a pas cette véritable à
mesure que le vélo électrique gagne du
terrain plusieurs y voit une opportunité
d'en faire leur principal mode de
transport tout en demeurant actif bien
sûr je n'utilise même pas l'électricité
mais c'est quand je suis une pente
régulière le vendant visage ça me permet
de lancer plus longtemps ici a dit
yassine radio canada montréal